welcome to this video against javelin
I'd see what do we get greenfeld the
Kings Indian okay you I've played this
classical with Knight d2 recently we
don't get it he's playing at this line
okay mm-hmm 97 yeah of course I have
forgotten everything I think this is a
move but I it's been ok there are some
tricks it seems Bishop d6 there's what
Queen f6 okay f5 22i think yeah okay
this is this as a playable line I had
looked this up Bishop f4 I think if I'm
not confusing things which is easily
easily possible I didn't really study
the classical King zinan in big detail I
was just looking at some lines not all
of them yeah f4 bishop f2 that looks
nice for black at first because he gets
the e5 square but i also have ideas i
have the the c5 braids the question is
if I need before for that or not
probably not Yemen I will I can also
play Knight B 3 and then c5 the d6 poll
after all is weak would have been
interesting for him to also consider
Bishop to g5
instead of night 25 an interesting
position one possibly important motif is
Nigeria okay so he seems to go for that
maybe well okay I have to do this this
anyway if I get in c5 I should play it
so no use in spending much time on that
okay so he really is going for this for
this attacking idea with Nigeria yeah
it's a it's it's there no doubt okay
Bishop c4 maybe
okay 93 I can really just take I'm also
with Bishop c4 I'm setting up things
like Queen takes a FOIA if the night has
moved let's say Nagi three takes and
then Queenie aphorism all also Queen the
six of course
ok
so Queen d6 is going to play Queen edge
for wow ok
hmm Jimmy it's not really threatening
that much but still feels kind of kind
of uncomfortable yeah not sure that this
this is really threatening anything even
Queen too XD 6 as possible
the main problem is i said i'm spending
time here for not much Bishop age to
Bishop page 293 jake peavy 1 and that's
it with the attack
i'm also not threatening ever to take
the bishop so it's not so not so clear
I'm actually continuing maybe 94 to eat
two or something it's not so clear I'm
not threatening anything really I mean
possibly I don't need to but still I'm
not quite sure how to continue maybe if
55 is actually a threat if 546 now that
that is a threat
I see it disconnected on I don't know
brand new account now he's them but
somehow not moving okay
this is threatening something hey I move
that I didn't consider at all okay 93
made hmm yeah I can play 92
I can and have to I guess
non-threatening okay so he's starting
the Hail Mary counter-attack let's see I
mean I can actually take some of this
stuff rope the eight maybe coming I mean
Bishop g2 is not a threat really isn't
cooked ate
maybe this one I don't know time was
just a piece really so Quincy seven
years check so don't see TX Bishop takes
is fairly safe I think 95 but it's not
it's not going to happen anytime soon
and I'm spending too much time it is
fair it's a fairly simple position
actually
check check check check check check
check check check check check check
black forfeits on time my primos was
just at the right moment I could get
some some next gear it's good to be
quicker whoo yeah I'm kind of rusty with
those pure metals I don't know why whoo
okay yeah I spend a bit too much time
when when the tech really was was over
yeah yeah this is this is always a funny
way to attack here with bishop age four
and so on so the compass always against
the computer of course this kind of
attack is completely useless as it will
defend mercilessly cd6 and black resins
is what the butt stock fish is giving
yeah it's difficult to relieve to do
this kind of thing just take it yeah I
mean important is of course that here
are not taking I'm just moving the king
and this is this is not really doing
much I can I'm just right here to cover
the square okay well this wasn't a bad
defense Queen d6 know as possible okay I
wanted to to be be safe here
quindi 6 and this is a funny move really
yeah it is I mean computer is just like
+ + 1.6 or something but still has to be
played Bishop you wanna okay I have to
do this this yeah and I can also take
the bishop if I want but I mean the h3
bishop so what I'm saying but this was
okay it was just really it is completely
okay just keeping things under control
yanti I took me a moment to get into the
right check the right stride let's say
94s is just totally winning 495 well
okay but I'm glad to to a one that okay
thanks for watching